now obviously the lots of fans of James
McAvoy's work all over the place but one
particular fan I think you were aware
you're aware of the lady the balloon
bottler ria a Norman
yeah it's her name you know she's here
Maria's here where's Rhea Norman hello
Ian order so now so really now you make
balloon models of other people but you
do a lot of James I do yeah
so it's that because he's easy to mock
lot of balloons or are you a fan you're
a fan I'm a huge fan oh thanks yeah I
think you became aware of Ria's work
when you saw this picture this is a four
of your characters from the movie split
right created using balloons here they
know that's a stick he's holding I think
I don't actually remember him holding us
there in the film it was all in
something
and then you all remember at the film
atonement yes so imagine what would that
beautiful scene look like if we created
using balloons here you are as Professor
X oh that noggin
professor abstract you think you would
think that is perfect for balloon work
thank you it's harder than you think
[Applause]
it's an upturn finally finally mr.
Tumnus oh here we go mr. Tumnus there
you are Oh dorable here is mr. Tumnus in
blue but now so we you know these are
just pictures but we thought now if
you're looking there Rhian you're
thinking she seems a bit red in the face
a little breathless it's because she's
been backstage all pumping away thing or
blowing what I imagine pumping
one of the I mean you know it's 2019
yeah those anymore
gentlemen please
let's meet balloon James MacAvoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but is on the shirt single oh just be oh
it's lovely be here it's lovely shaving
your balls
I was trailer Cup the blood yeah steam
it off thanks for having its own poem
ladies and gentlemen balloon boys
[Applause]
okay McAvoy is very drunk
[Music]
you